this next comment hasn't even performed
but i'm already laughing
please give a warm welcome this is a
true legend
to the goal hey everyone what's your
favorite comic judy gold back here at
bananamores
so great to be here i just love this
place it's like home
i mean it's really like home i mean it's
it's basically home but uh yeah it's
great to be here
um speaking of home i'm in a
relationship i
uh i'm actually a menopausal lesbian in
a relationship with another
menopausal lesbian which is not easy
because first of all
she's a therapist so nothing i say is
benign
everything has some hidden meaning oh
you meant to say this oh you really mean
that
you know i'm a comedian i already hate
myself i don't need you
validating everything that i think you
know what i'm saying but
it's amazing i've realized i've been in
relationships with women my entire adult
life and i have to say
the one thing they all have in common is
that no fight
ever ends i'm not kidding you know elise
and i will have a fight
um and i think it's over it's done i've
moved on and then like 20 minutes later
at least they'll come over and be like
judy um do you feel like we resolved
that
like a hundred percent yeah absolutely
okay just checking i just want to know
20 minutes go by judy can we just
um can we just process that for a few
more minutes because
i really need to have some closure oh my
god absolutely elisa
that's so great you know i was just
about to sit down with my book
and a latte and i was thinking oh my god
i really hope we can rehash that fight
we had three days ago
about how i watched an episode of the
crown and didn't tell you which makes me
a compulsive liar and is why none of my
friends trust me
and i was hoping oh maybe we could talk
about that ad nauseam
maybe take a break for dinner and then
you could bring it up right before bed
how does that work
good yeah relationships are hard but the
beginning
the beginning is so good remember the
beginning ah
when you were so in love and you
couldn't keep your hands off each other
there were a couple of things alisa did
in the beginning of our relationship i
was like all right
that is eventually gonna get on my
nerves but i didn't really care
because you know we were
making out all the time it is daytime
daytime so uh
here's one of the things i can't take
anymore so whenever alisa sneezes i'm
not kidding
every time she sneezes she literally
says
uh chew and it's like really loud it's
like a
chew a chew
and i'm like lisa what is that she's
like it's a sneeze
no that's not a sneeze that's a sneeze
plus drama you added in no one says a
chew
when they sneeze it just doesn't happen
it's not like when you pass gas it comes
out fart
cough cough
all right well that's it for me uh folks
i'll see you soon at my home club
bananamores don't forget to tip your
weight staff uh
try the uh vegan veal and uh
i'll be here all forever good night
folks
magnificent walk after hearing those
smart line shakespeare is like
who is this person
you